verstehen sie was ich machen trick und
vom sport mehr fordere die reisen
erzählt mir mehr sagte william für acht
teams und alle teams kamen heute mal
bewerteten abendfüllende show schrieb
ein anderer publikationen und wird
wahrscheinlich nach seiner telefon
tätige und klavier das programm ein
solches tagesprogramm ist typisch für
ihn
fabian unteregger ist nicht nur ein
bekannter comedian er ist auch arzt
pilot und forscher oder wie er es nennt
unternehmer ein jahr unterwegs mit
fabian unteregger soll uns zeigen wie
bewältigt er sein volles programm
wie schafft er den spagat zwischen den
verschiedenen welten davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
seit einem jahr tot fabian unteregger
mit seinem soloprogramm doktorspiele
durchs land mit erfolg die vieler seiner
shows sind ausverkauft
dieser abend ist ein highlight der
tournee nitrat er vor größerem publikum
auf
[Musik]
das eben so wie später so richtig es ist
alles da es gibt sogar die es gibt
ich meine wie folgen starb mit mit mir
früher oder wenn du klingst du rückgang
lichtschein christian weiss alles was es
braucht ist mit freude da ist natürlich
klar ist dass wir 200 leiharbeiter
das war ein völlig das bruchsaler
dadurch oft heißt es habe in der bühne
august situation ist komplex zwischen
dem prinzip völlig zunichte und
wirtschaft die ablieferung trostlos die
probe ist zu ende
fabian unteregger ist bereit für die
show er spielt an diesem abend in zürich
vor rund 1000 zuschauern
[Musik]
15 minuten vor showbeginn sein
berufskollege stefan büsser moderiert
ihn heute abend an
[Musik]
im finish schöne frauen wie ich dass ich
war das ist so traurig was ich wird mit
den marken gab es einzig ich bin
natürlich und ich wollte im publikum
sitzt auch seine mutter sie war schon
immer vom musischen talent ihres sohnes
fasziniert
und ich habe universitätsspital basel
fabian unteregger nimmt er an einem
forschungstag teil anfang 2015 hat er
sein medizinstudium abgeschlossen
nun macht der forschungen zum
menschlichen stimmorgan er ist also
nicht nur stimmenimitator sondern auch
stehen forscher heute ist der 39-jährige
in basel um seine arbeit zu präsentieren
und einer fachjury zu erklären
ist dramatisch
dieses blog ort in der kasse
du hast du dazu gekommen für mich sagen
sie gespannt was los ist
und gestank muss auch komplett logisch
gewesen dann sofort anschauen sehen
schon ist die jury da
die post geht strom funktion vom neuling
slonings muskulatur um frau mich nur
prozent jetzt 15 eck und quentin hüne 14
cntt herrn tribünen müssen wir haben bei
jedem von den tönen mit einem schuss
knapp das ganze in das 3d bild
verwandelt
seit vier jahren forscht er bereits auf
diesem gebiet die erkenntnisse aus
seiner forschung will er dieses jahr
publizieren
töten
für seine präsentation hat er am
forschungstag eine auszeichnung erhalten
von seinem forschungsgebiet ist er aber
trotzdem überzeugt
[Musik]
zum gebiet wo er seine erkenntnisse wird
er dieses jahr noch an internationalen
kongressen präsentieren
und wenn der plan aufgeht dafür den
doktortitel bekommen kirche bühl in
zürich der diesjährige redner an der
maturafeier der kantonsschule wiedikon
ist der ehemalige schüler fabian
unteregger
es sieht alles noch wie am ersten
schultag
es ist heiko neumann hat bibliothek die
charme womit wachstum hindert sie
gründete dapd
nach einigen witzen wird fabian
unteregger ernst er wolle den
maturantinnen und maturanten mit seiner
rede mut machen sagt er
nach dem motto ich bin weg der chalkosin
rasant viktors spätprogramm beworben und
in absolut passiert nach der matur hatte
ich mich bedeutet jeder 20 unter ab sagt
kassiert ich habe viel absage kassiert
die absage kassiert aus der hose
verteilt also ich bin ein anderer mensch
als dauer nicht durchgemacht haben doch
so wirklich viel erfahrung der
versammlung natürlich kann dieses
vertrauen also so einfach generiert ohne
stolz hatte schäfer 20 jahren auf die
bühne also oder andere ist auch vorträge
halten oder laut kutscher ja ich bin
froh bin ich jetzt auch und ich bin und
da zu sein wo er heute ist brauchte er
viel fleiß und ehrgeiz
damit und mit seiner schnellen
auffassungsgabe viele schon zu
schulzeiten auf
die hüpfburg sind die einzigen täter
unter dem motto mit zwei lang die
sachsen zusätzlich gibt es das 50
naturwissenschaften faszinierten den
begabten schüler sein erstes studium
lebensmittelwissenschaft brachte ihn
denn auch an die eth zürich
wir treffen fabian unteregger und seine
eltern bei der politesse hier hat er
viele jahre verbracht nach seinem ersten
studium und dem höheren lehramt begann
der unermüdliche mit einem zweiten
medizin
dass er sich dann eben mehr und mehr der
comedy widmete gefiel seinem vater
zuerst gar nicht sein vater ist ökonom
seine mutter soziologin
sie sind froh dass ihr sohn mehrere
standbeine hat für fabian unteregger war
von anfang an klar
er sieht sich nicht als künstler sondern
als unternehmer ich bin einfach
hochgradig ungarisch frau und frau achte
genau richtig so ich sehe wo sich voll
darauf tönt oder will die verhalten sich
anschlüsse und mir macht das hat mich
wirklich zusammen sind freut und ich das
große glück sich jetzt nicht
wirtschaftlicher angst muss die eliten
durch vaters habe weder haben von seinen
eltern ist es wichtig dass er trotz
seines erfolges am boden bleibt
wie war das eine sehr ruhiger mensch
sich die nervöse das muss immer disco
dann aber eigentlich trocken
ich sehe menschen
die private seite die seine mutter
beschreibt können wir höchstens erahnen
fabian unteregger kontrolliert sehr
genau was er von sich preisgibt
er bestimmt auch was er nicht zeigen
will dazu gehören sein auto seine
wohnung und seine freundin das ist ihm
zu privat bin ich glaube ja auch ich
mache privat vorsorgen werden auch
gemüse sport zufolge vor dem fernseher
hocken und was alter zu erhöhen
ob es ist heute so dass ich jetzt fängt
das ist überhaupt privat ist privat und
fielen damit werde ihr der lage große
lüfter den öffentlichen fabian zeigt er
gerne einem großen publikum mit seinem
soloprogramm tritt er jede woche an
einem anderen ort darauf für diesen
auftritt ist er in sankt gallische unter
wasser gefahren
[Musik]
nach dem soundcheck schlafe er gerne ein
paar minuten er erzählt oft dass er sehr
schnell regenerieren können und deshalb
das große pensum gut bewältigen
mitunter funktionierte so für die fusion
beschlossen
ich würde jetzt verschiedene
wahrscheinlich das womit der besitzer
und spieler ausgab empfohlen
so hat es noch nie waren gestellt und
hengste knie
noch zwei stunden bis schon beginnen
fabian unteregger geht mit seinen
technikern abendessen
es ist so wie sich hochgradig
unvernünftig ob das macht das ist das
ist super da
christine clauß aber ich finde man ist
wie so viele wie sie forscht beweisen
dass es auch so geht das eigentlich
alles geht wenn man nur genug einsatz
gibt scheint fabian unteregger das
lebensmotto zu sein
doch niemand
[Applaus]
diese woche die punkten für sein
programm doktorspiele schrieber
größtenteils szene sowie 22 wie nach
jeder show verabschiedet er seine
zuschauer persönlich
natürlich erst einmal dankbar dass die
daten sind noch ist für mich schön die
rolle des staates und streit
ausgebrochen und themen zu ruhm und es
ist nun einmal ein kontakt mit dem
publikum zu michael faso zwischen bühne
von everydns.net ruhiger und zwischen
ruhiger und wie das so schön ich wurde
er profi aber die männer spaß
wir sind in genua fabian unteregger
nimmt an einem internationalen
ärztekongress teil um die erkenntnisse
seiner stimme forschung zu präsentieren
mit ihm angereist ist claudia sturm der
seine arbeit betreut und mit dem forscht
die forschung ist derzeit die einzige
verbindung zur medizin für fabian
unteregger die priorität liegt bei
seiner karriere als comedian die frage
ob und wann er eine stelle als
assistenzarzt antritt ist noch offen
ich bin eine situation wo mir erwartet
hat dass sie dass sie so lässt sich das
das so so so stattfindet und ja wenn ich
das mache ich heiße sonne sehr gut die
frage ich hätte gerne hätten antwortet
ruf natürlich weiß ich wer mit wenig
spannend in kontakt was die standzeiten
und einer stop me now
unternehmenstätigkeit ist im moment
einfach schwierig
claudio stark hält den ersten vortrag
fabian unteregger ist angespannt im
gegensatz zu auftritten als comedian hat
er bei medizin vorträgen wenig erfahrung
das ist erst sein vierter kongress
[Musik]
fabian unteregger erreicht sein ziel
seine forschungen kann er demnächst
erfolgreich in einem amerikanischen
wissenschaftsjournal publizieren
der doktortitel ist ihm damit so gut wie
sicher nachdem ärztekongress bleibt noch
zeit für ein kurzes italienisches
mittagessen mit claudio stock er hat
fabian unteregger forschung die letzten
jahre betreut und schätzt die
zusammenarbeit den spagat zwischen
medizin und comedy sieht er aber nicht
als dauerlösung ich da bloß aufpassen
dass das nicht notwendig die gefahr
besteht natürlich und das wirst du sich
bewusst dass wenn man es auch gemacht
oder riesiges pensum vor 7,4 also dass
du das ganze irgendwie in der balance
halten und durch das tor
einige schadlos über das ist nicht
einfach
auch wir staunen oft wie fabian
unteregger alles unter einen hut kriegt
doch er versichert uns immer wieder dass
er sich nicht überlastet fühlen
er habe seinen energiehaushalt gut unter
kontrolle und planer genau ein weil er
eine pause einlege
[Musik]
statt in der freien zeit auf der faulen
haut zu liegen hat er in diesem jahr für
die erfüllung eines großen traums
gebüffelt vier jahre hat die ausbildung
gedauert
diesen sommer hat er nun die prüfung zum
helikopter pilot abgelegt
du wirklich wie überwogen kommt
darstellen
das tut sachen in der hand hast ja also
ist auch ein kleiner witz verstanden
gefühlt auch nicht sehen jetzt die börse
ginge dann werden die dann will der
österreicher willi bereich überzeugt bin
dass es gut ich hab ich will überhaupt
nicht alles kontrollieren
das war ein riesiges jetzt mal ja wo
sind denn niemand kontrolliert
zielvorgabe wie mit der tiefe und
dadurch viel improvisation darin extrem
fit und bin ich ja also ich habe
unglaublich viel in bruck nach durfte
bühne und ja nun schon wenige meter nach
oben das ist wahrscheinlich ein zufall
obwohl es nach allem anderen zweifellos
zählt
fabian unteregger hebt ab wie so oft in
diesem jahr das ziel vor augen das
steuer fest im griff
mit beeindruckendem ehrgeiz und einsatz
erreicht er was er sich vornimmt und
sucht sich das nächste ziel
kaum hat er eins erreicht
[Musik]